sean and camilla explain how their  breakup inspired new music i mean when  you're gone is really about a breakup it  was just me kind of processing what it  feels like to be on my own again and  learn how to cope and be there for  myself it's me kind of falling in and  out of love and the ups and downs of  that i felt like maybe i was putting too  much pressure on one person to provide  every support that i needed that's life  you're on the ground crying in the  bathroom floor and then you'll have  feelings for another person again and  then you'll be crying on the bathroom  floor again things just change you never  know what's around the corner